i think this song is exactly a couple of
friends
we are new friends but we feel like old
friends and we
bonded over actual life on tour
and hanging out together and hanging out
in wanda and partying
and singing on stage together and this
song just feels like a natural
transition to like
the after part yeah what she said
we met because um miranda scared the
crap out of me by coming to a show and i
was very very starstruck
and all i wanted all i wanted was for
her to think that i was cool
and i felt like she liked me after that
night and you were always nice to me
anytime i kind of saw you around
and um and so by the time that
well i guess what the torque the tour
came up yeah and then we did
yeah the all-girl tour which was so
amazing and all of those
amazing wonderful ideas were all hers so
when when
like we got to do fooled around and fell
in love it was
just a wonderful way to showcase female
talent
and you're such an amazing person to
want to
like just put that on the forefront and
really showcase people that you respect
and you like working with
and to like really give power back to
women and i respect her to no end
oh my god you look amazing
when the idea of like the whole music
video came about music videos can be
really tense
and they can be really kind of stiff and
it can be a lot for me it can be a lot
of pressure on what do i look like how
do i get the best performance
and so the thought of a fun kind of um
music video especially for a fun song
that i'm doing with my friend um this is
probably the most fun music video i've
ever had it's really
it's easy and it's been great the
directors are great the team's been
awesome but it's also
like a lot less pressure when you get to
perform with someone that's
you know yeah fun and loves what they do
and
we haven't been on stage in a really
long time you know and so this was like
a pretend concert but we both got to
jump around and
yeah you know wear glitter and we needed
to yeah
[Music]
the fact that it does coincide with you
know
my soon-to-be wedding and miranda
just you just got married but yeah she's
still a new word
so um loves in the air and uh it just
it just was a great video and i actually
held her dress and took her shoes off
like a tomato on her honestly
she was my maid of honor today